Speaker 1: . Bernie Sanders almost immediately
after the Derrick Shervin verdict, again,
three guilty counts, potentially decades in
prison, sentencing in eight weeks.
Bernie Sanders using similar language to that
which many are using.
And many of our viewers used on the live stream
where we covered the verdict that the SHERVIN
verdict is accountability, but it is not justice
and it does not fix issues of systemic racism
in the United States.
Bernie Sanders sending a few tweets.
Let's look at them saying, quote, The jury's
verdict delivers accountability for Derek
Shervin, but not justice for George Floyd.
Real justice for him and to many others can
only happen when we build a nation that fund.
A mentally respects the human dignity of every
person, Bernie, going on to say the trauma
and tragedy of George Floyds murder must never
leave us.
It was a manifestation of a system that callously
devalues the lives of black people.
Finally, Bernie, saying, our struggle now
is about justice, not justice on paper, but
real justice in which all Americans live their
lives free of oppression.
We must boldly root out the cancer of systemic
racism and police violence against people
of color.
So certainly this is a step forward.
If it is a new era of more police understanding
that they are in a position as police officers
that can be dangerous for them, there's no
denying that they are in a position where
they are put into situations that are, by
their nature, difficult and that require exercising
judgment about what is the risk to them and
to others of the individuals that they encounter.
But the sort of free pass or close to free
pass that it's not my opinion that statistically
there has been understandings over the last
decade and a half.
As I mentioned earlier, out of 140 cases of
charges against officers for murder or manslaughter,
of the 97 cases that have been resolved, seven
guilty verdicts, OK, that this may be a change
in terms of what they can get away with.
And much like when Barack Obama was elected
president, it didn't end racism.
In fact, it it arguably coalesced racism and
xenophobia and subsequently led to Donald
Trump.
Understand the backwards nature of that.
This is potentially a step forward, but pervasive
ignorance is not going anywhere anytime soon.
It is maybe the start.
It is maybe a glimmer of hope.
It would be great if it were true that this
was some major resolution to America's problems.
But it's not.
And again, I want to repeat something that
I mentioned in the first segment about the
verdict.
It is an odd situation where you have the
state of Minnesota saying we are going to
deal with what we believe is a wrong that
was committed.
Right.
The state saying from what we saw, we we are
charging Derek Chauvin and we are prosecuting
Derrick Chauvin.
But Derrick Chauvin is, at least in a sense,
a consequence of the policing system overseen
by that very same state of Minnesota.
And you can make a similar analogy to other
states around the country, different states
dealing with issues of police force to different
degrees.
So we are now going to have to see what what
is next.
President Joe Biden speaking last night alongside
Kamala Harris and others and saying we we
now have a problem that hopefully we can start
to deal with.
And the question of how is it going to be
dealt with and to what degree and will police
departments play a role as part of the solution
or not?
And of course, police departments aren't one
thing and there are dramatically different
police departments in the United States.
Just as a reminder disclaimer, I know people
get mad when I do this.
I am not an abolish the police guy.
I am a reformed the police guy.
And I have extensive clips on our YouTube
channel about why that's my framework.
This is not you know, I know that there were
some who reacted to this by saying all cops
are bastards, abolish the police.
This guilty verdict proves we get rid of police.
Go talk to them if you want to figure out
why they think that.
That's not my view.
I've made clear, you know, my eight to ten
point plan of police reforms that that I would
put in place.
So the question I have for you and you can
let me know, find me on Twitter at David Pakman
or elsewhere.
What do you hope this verdict means and what
do you think it most likely means, if anything?
Bigger picture.
All right.
Find me on Twitter David Pakman.
We'll take a quick break.
And we will have extensive reaction from all
sorts of different people to these three guilty
verdicts that we got yesterday.